guys this bit you're gonna what is going
to dismantle the whole thing for Alex
[Music]
babe I gave you a job three times now
compare that with the clip that you see
after the cut as you can see not only
has his hands positions change I mean if
I'm surprised I have to explain this to
you because it's obvious what's happened
here but justing this is a contention
that I hear all the time if something
can come from nothing why doesn't it
happen all the time things can just pop
into existence why doesn't the car just
appear right here well there's a simple
reason for that whoa whoa whoa oh whoa I
thought you said you don't before the
video starts guys check our sponsors and
natures blend they specialize in premium
Ethiopian black seed products their
products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the Sunnah the
website is in the description link below
you can also use the discount code Salam
ten for 10% of their products what are
you guys waiting for okay
I said I wanna come where I'm it's way
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are winning
shot welcome to this video in this video
we're going to be Angela analyzing some
allegations that's been from from
towards Hamid a German we're gonna be
just we're gonna be fair if we seek a
job being wrong we're gonna tell him
we're gonna call him out for as well
because Allah says no hold on speak the
truth even if it's against yourself or
your kin so that means the Quran comes
above hijab and every other Muslim so
we're not here to defend individual
Muslims the Quran is our criteria so of
course this video of being cosmic hijab
yeah now I'm talking about cosmic
skeptic and Muhammad hijab caused me to
jump over them I'll be analyzing them
but there's another reason I'll call the
cosmic seed job because I believe cosmic
skeptic is throwing a lot of hedge abs
now what do we mean by that yeah I like
my abortions making wonderfully talking
about let me tell you I'm talking about
hijab is something that covers the
beauty of an individual a woman it
covers their beauty so I believe that
what alex is doing is obvious even
though alex has referred to women in
hijabs
bags inanimate objects I was shopping
yesterday or inanimate objects in my bag
so this is what he referred to my
sweetie watch that clip at some house
makes a good point
times if we go into you know if I went
into Somalia and said you shouldn't be
putting women in bags they'd probably
say yes they would accuse you of I think
he uses the term cultural imperialism
which is so you guys saw it for yourself
two individuals sitting there talking
about Somali woman has been in bags so
he refers to women in her jobs as that
sadly yeah and if there's any Somali
youtubers that you know couples or
individuals please send that footage to
them they can react and see how they
feel about being caught being in bags or
their mothers and sisters being in bags
the reason why I'm kind of cosmic a job
is because cosmic skeptic is throwing
all these hid jobs coverings over the
main argument and is using all these
other irrelevant really not major points
so we're gonna go for the one by one cuz
I've watched all of cosmic skeptics
videos cosmic skeptic had a debate with
Mohammed II job and one other from
either side and the debate was called
does Islam explain reality better than
atheism so do not forget that does Islam
explain reality but then atheism
Mohammed hijabs main argument was from
argument from contingency now I'm gonna
explain that to you guys inshallah so
before you guys think are big words I
don't know what's going on here let me
give you some definition just keep in
mind I'm gonna make this very simple I'm
gonna use a clear analogy which it's all
going to make sense just look at this
analogy every time I talk it just look
at it and it will make perfect sense
here just to give few definitions yeah
I'm gonna give the definition says well
yeah so we believe hijab argument is the
following from contingency there are
dependent things within our universe now
we know what dependent means dependent
and contingent is kind of synonym yeah
it's anonymous both words yeah dependent
is it's something that relies on
something else
for its existence contingent or the
pendulum use any of them here so I'll
repeat again relies on something else
for his existence we say those things
that relies on something else in his
existence it can it has to have a main
source of power main source that's
giving rise to it so we say there has to
be something independent or necessary so
these can be seen as synonyms is war
here independent necessary an
independent thing is something that is
not non relied for its own existence
yeah it does arrive
existence cold war lava add Allahu
semeth Allah is self-sufficient right is
necessary so self-sufficient pre-eternal
post-eternal one cost that is hijab
argument so what I have on the screen
for you guys here is the argument I'm
going to use and anytime to get
computers to look at that
you'll make perfect sense so for example
so this is a job that I came across a
long time ago but it bought the idea for
fan I found it on Google yeah so we have
here Wikipedia yeah
Wikipedia don't forget the definition we
gave Wikipedia saying I know everything
proudly like I am the soul I know
everything and then Google comes inside
your hotel sorry hold on a second hold
on a second here I found everything so
and then sorry guys
anyways so as I was saying so Google
says I found everything Facebook comes
along and says hey I know everyone so
they just boasting you know I'm the you
know like source of power yes and the
internet comes and says yo relax I own
you yes so internet why Wikipedia Google
Facebook only what you need Internet to
be surviving yeah so internet comes and
acts like you know he's the necessary
the source of power that they all have
to exist and then computer comes and
says you're mode
I'll give you life not literally but I
said I gave you life so the computers
come into correct internet and saying
you're look I gave you enough relax
yourself you own everything yet I gave
you life ok so he's saying I am the
necessary you guys are all contingent ok
so that's what he's saying
now electricity comes around and says he
keep talking yeah and so I'm not gonna
use it
yeah so ER is our argument in a nutshell
hijab is trying to say just this
Wikipedia Google Facebook internet
computer we can see this as our planet
like for example my computer my computer
relies on electricity electricity relies
on power and they say from the Sun Algy
music yeah from the Sun the Sun relies
on the the galaxy the galaxy relies on
the universe the universe relies on what
the
Yunis relies on what that is the crux of
the matter of the argument he jabbers
bringing form I'm gonna need on the
screen have a look at that because we're
saying that we need an unnecessary
uncaused
independent being to make sense of
everything he's the ultimate source of
power that is the argument of hey John
did cosmic skeptic or chassé cosmic
hijab touch upon that let's see so I
watched all of this video the one he's
done exposing his job after one whole
entire year he came out he didn't
address these in the debate and even
after the paper only for some reason one
year after the debate to me that show
kind of kind of shows that this whole
news let me tell you why these are the
points abroad yeah now let's not forget
the title does Islam explain reality
better than atheism so hijab is going
there trying to explain the system
explain reality better or does atheism
and that's what's cosmic hijab cosmic
skipped into it yeah the first thing
that he brings in is a video exposing
Muhammad he job is a following the
debate wasn't prepared by Oxford
University it was prepared by Oxford for
his version of this video is titled
Islam versus atheism Oxford University
debate this debate was not hosted by
Oxford University as it says in the
event description this was hosted by the
Oxford forum which is a student-run
society okay
argument see hijab made the grave
mistake and he wrote Oxford University
while go not so formal okay okay
hey jab you're wrong you you are wrong
how dare you do that okay
we'll tell Kay job is wrong it's Oxford
uniform not Oxford University but hold
on a second Alex does that have okay
let's this oppose okay let's put that to
a side can you answer the argument now
that he died was put forth from the
argument from contingency he has it
doesn't touch it okay let's cut I
carried on watching her for him bounce
rate in the next video I mean in the
next part as he carries on a loss
doesn't know Quran he says
[Music]
ooh did you spot that did you see what
happened there let's watch that again
I lost doesn't report on it says okay so
there appears to be some kind of cut now
was this just a cut to a different
camera or something like that well let's
analyze this cut and see what actually
happened here okay so before the cut
what we can see here these are the
things to take notice of most pressingly
firstly muhammad hijab is wearing suit
and tie and notice how the tie is tucked
into the jacket also notice that he's
wearing a lapel microphone on the tie
that's clipped on to pick up his voice
now compare that with the clip that you
see after the cut as you can see not
only has his hands positions change I
mean I'm surprised I have to explain
this to you because it's obvious what's
happened here but Justin not sure I mean
it looks to me as though maybe the
slates of wood behind Muhammad in the
second clip are closer together they're
like thinner slabs or something and okay
so now what he's seeing is that you can
see that he's seen that hijab this this
is debate angle and then all of a sudden
the angle changes and then he sports
like it's my case you know you have
these movies these guys who watch movies
and they try to catch out mistakes made
in the movie what alex is doing this
that he's had a massive founding like oh
my gosh you see he hasn't got the mic
and he's ty is somewhere else and this
thing is popping up this it looks a bit
out of place and the background it's
like he has all of a sudden I get you
ask for a job I just gave you it but you
said you want a hijab okay sorry
which color this one this one yeah
sorry guys
anyways so he is making it seem alex is
making a scene as if he found something
like that like they we all Chris
orchestrated the whole thing and they
were so stupid that they did forgot to
put the mic on and make it look like
that
Alex it was done on purpose and the
reason it was done on purpose is because
it from what Mohammed is you have told
me that it was being interrupted when he
was reciting the Quran so he free filmed
that bit it was done on purpose
intentionally we wasn't trying to use
green screen in the back and trying to
make it seem so nobody sees it
it's so obvious you can see for yourself
for yourself it's so blatantly obvious
Alex
so the way you're making it seem that
you found out something like we're
stupid we're gonna put the mic and make
it seem you can see the different angle
now once again Alex are you gonna touch
up on the argument the argument for
contingency or are you going to follow
another hijab over it yeah
meaning cosmic a [ __ ] meaning you're
gonna fall another hijab over and just
cover it just make it like it will cost
you on these petty issues yeah Oxford
Union Oxford form add in a video in
there like he's adding a new argument in
there just awkward and yeah
now with okay the third point is going
to be the point where he'll address
hijab and break down his argument for
contingency no he come up it comes up
with the debate that I uploaded with
Jonathan McClatchy has four hundred and
sixty nine thousand views and eighteen
thousand four hundred comments okay
that's the kind of ratio that I tend to
get on a video and it's especially a
debate like this one
okay so nearly half a million views and
eighteen thousand eighteen and a half
thousand comments
compare that to Muhammad his jobs debate
which has more views it's got just over
seven hundred thousand views and how
many comments 661 that how is it that
the comments are not appearing and I was
thinking okay
seems like a valid point so he made a
screenshot and in his screenshot there's
about seven hundred thousand something
views on his video of the video and only
five hundred six hundred comments and
now that's surprising to what is
surprising to you Alice because we don't
know him we know him yet he puts
comments for review because a lot of
people come insulting
the way it made this out to be is like
you like somebody in the comment section
was gonna bring a mad argument and
hijabs whole video was going to be
dismantled and he was that no we
couldn't bear to do that Alex for real I
can show you many examples one of those
is the debate he had with David Wood we
destroyed an Annihilator David would
finish his career off and there's over
1.6 million views and there's about just
over a thousand 1500 pound 1500 comments
yeah okay so hold on a second are you
gonna accuse him of that as well when he
acts is this man - that is he scared
that somebody in the comment section is
gonna come and come on Alex he holds it
for a review I do it the other way
around
I let comments go and I delete the ones
that insult our religion yeah he jabbed
us the other way around he refused them
and allows the ones that are not
insulting I'm sure he has no problem
with someone criticizing someone
criticizing his stance you know he
doesn't have that so please that's
another petty issue and I've shown you
examples that he does is another video
so again you've thrown another hijab
covered hijab mean and covering if you
watch the video - the main argument
which is on the screen the argument from
contingency but let's see
is he gonna answer it on the next point
he doesn't again happens that it cut out
at the moment I was talking about the
the Quranic verse which has the
injunction about hitting wives right now
when I started talking about that how
the Quran permits men to beat their
wives my microphone cut out right now
that might be a mysterious but those
wives from whom you fear arrogance first
advise them then if they persist forsake
them in bed then what what comes next
well of course we have no way to know
because my microphone cut out at the
exact moment that I said and finally
strike them which came about in surah
nisa verse 34 where Allah so Allah says
if you have this with your wife
tell them first advise him they don't
listen move from the bed nor intimacy
and if they don't listen beat them
firstly this out of context but Alex is
claiming something a supernatural some
kind of a phenomena that happened yeah
or some kind of a plot
yeah but when he was just about to say
and beat them the audio Kyle so the way
alex is going
about this once again he hasn't touched
upon the main argument and he's using
irrelevant points yeah
he's claiming as if he came across his
the first english-speaking person in the
whole wide world came across his crown
verse and he can't wait for everybody to
see it and that's that moment of time
the limelight and he opens the Koran and
is about to read it and sabor says no no
one can know about that verse and his
job gives him a scientist amor and says
come and support once runs and he goes
didn't my consist Newt annex this
argument this contention has been
brought up left right center for the
donkey years and it's been debunked and
it's being exposed and it's been put
that is out of context you're making a
special case as if you're the only one
that's about to come with that and
you're my god mute the mic got mute so
many times even when he Chad was talking
and you know that right we you know that
his mic was muted as well so it's
happened many times why are you making a
scene that he was about to bring that
knockout blow and they just muted you
well you done a video explaining it come
on once again has cosmic hijab the
cosmic a job what could be scripted has
he touched upon the main argument from
contingency the hijab boo
know what he's done he's flown another
hijab like my wife's asked for her jobs
every time yeah
throwing it again to the contentious
argument so nobody sees it let's see if
you would address it on the fifth point
I'm not sure what the legalities are on
that but there were four conditions that
were mentioned in the email pertaining
to how I could use the footage the first
was that I'm only allowed to use a
specified forty minutes of the debate
I'm only allowed to include the opening
statements that is to say I can't upload
the full debate again this is
potentially reasonable because they want
people to be directed to their version
of the video because they've filmed it
so fair enough that's okay he says that
I am Ron message dim and giving these
conditions that you can't manipulate
with the comments you cannot manipulate
with the video audio and they give these
comments etc so why is doing is using
reverse psychology so what that means is
he's seen
no I want to put the video up I wouldn't
put the video well why was in you asking
it for about a year ago and now you're
asking for it now what what's all of
sudden change now anyone that's watching
the debate could see that hijab is and
I'm just seeing me Allah preserve his
intentions people have said how his
orders in hijab are often on the neck on
atheist and they're people that you just
don't expect sabor common sources
Mohammed II job are people we're
atheists are just ops matter like we for
Muslims are just these barbaric cavemen
well they're coming and scolding
atheists and that's what happened in
that very debate and now you're using
the verse psychology it's as if it's as
if like two people I don't know like
listen I'm a vital guy I don't get just
it here two people having a fight one
gets knocked out and the kadhi is not
that says look yeah you put video on
your challenge channel hey you didn't
give me the video to put it on my
channel how's that you're just gonna put
a video on your channel that you got
knocked out this reverse psychology no
give me the video give me the video let
me put on my channel what's that gonna
change it's not gonna show a footage of
somebody getting knocked down and that
is you said so leaving a product on all
your face channel it's just gonna make
it worse for you and that's the reason
you didn't ask for until now you're
making a whole new her about it now
you said that there was conditions given
and he's from Iowa it wasn't from IRA
the footage belongs to Salaam it belongs
to our organization not to Iowa yeah we
got someone we pay someone to film it
and the person who emailed she was my
teacher it was an era yeah it was an era
so again the comments section we
explained why that was the case
do you claiming that that some kind of a
you know distorted the context it wasn't
his job was reciting the Quran and
intentionally they added that bit
intentionally you didn't catch them out
they did it intentionally so that's out
the window and it was from Iowa it was
from us hope that's clear did you touch
upon the main argument of contingency
again no
you through another hijab point six now
surely his goal I'll give you two he
jabs you asked for different color I
give you the right color okay
which one do you want this one okay
this yeah thank you thank you okay guys
so maybe on the sixth point he will
touch upon it now this is very profound
this point is very firm because he has
every opportunity now because a very
issue now is not comments section it's
not your new clip I didn't it's not
Oxford Union also form the title and all
these other things it is that he's
claiming that Muhammad hijab took his
words out of context and he never
claimed to say the universe came from
nothing Amir how the universe came into
existence from nothing and by nothing ex
Nilo I want to know tell me how that's
possible metaphysically ontological you
cosmologically from first principles
give me the answer please okay I'm
beginning to get the impression that
Muhammad hijab wants me to justify my
claim that the universe began to exist
out of nothing okay
slight problem with that I never said
that Muhammad hijab has quoted me
quoting someone else's belief quoting me
quoting a belief that I don't agree with
and is claiming that I was making that
claim as doing was saying that look I'm
gonna grant you the premise mr. theist
that the universe began to exist in
order to help your argument but just so
you know for this to be of any relevance
to the argument it would have to be
beginning to exist out of nothing okay
so let's grant the premise that the
universe began to exist even though I
don't believe it but when the universe
did begin to exist it began to exist out
of nothing notice what's happened here
I've said I'm going to grant the premise
I then quoted the premise and then
Muhammad hijab has quoted me quoting the
premise and said that that's what I
believe let's watch this video very
carefully because I found something very
very very profound and he has every
opportunity in this very topic which is
about where the universe came from which
is hijab actual main point does he touch
upon it let's see if he jab wrongly
accused him but just with that out of
the way the the first most pressing
issue that I come across with this
argument this what's known as the
fallacy of composition you may already
be familiar with it
in effect the fallacy of composition
occurs when you take a characteristic of
the constituent parts of a whole and
apply that characteristic to the whole
itself so as an example picture if you
will a brick wall now the constituent
parts of the brick wall are of course
the bricks now we could be tempted to
make the argument every brick in the
wall is red
therefore the wall is red perfectly
sound nothing wrong with that and this
is why the fallacy is so seductive
because it works some of the time but
the fallacy lies in assuming that it
works all of the time which it does not
for example if we shrink the brick we
now might be tempted to say well every
brick is small therefore the wall is
small right well of course this isn't
the case so guys so now he's using the
compare the fallacy of composition
meaning for those who say for example
everything that begins to exist has of
course
therefore the it has a course he's
saying that's a fallacy so his argument
from the get-go of building he's
destroying the whole point of that the
universe has a course so his argument is
based on the composition of fallacy
which is used to dismantle the argument
that the universe had a course so now it
seems like he's and he's making a claim
that the universe didn't have a course
but it's gonna benefit that maybe he's
quoting someone else to carry on
Bertrand Russel in a famous BBC debate
but it this way I can illustrate what
seems to me your fallacy every man who
exists has a mother and it seems to me
that your argument is that therefore the
human race must have a mother but
obviously the human race hasn't a mother
that's a different logical sphere hey
every sheep in a herd has a mother but
the herd doesn't have a mother itself
everything in the universe may have a
cause but that doesn't mean that the
universe itself has a cause and this is
in effect the fallacy of composition so
he's quoting Bertrand Russell and once
again it's he's alluding to which I can
see he's alluding to his insinuating
that he's using the same argument from
the fallacy of composition to claim that
the universe doesn't have a course but
maybe he's just quoting Bertrand Russell
this carry on again what we're doing you
saying everything in the universe every
effect in the universe has a cause
therefore the universe itself has a
cause but this again is sort of another
form of the fallacy of composition you
can't apply the same logic to the
universe just because that logic applies
to things within the universe itself
you've heard for yourself now he's
supporting his argument saying no this
is again this is reaffirming that the
universe doesn't have a cause
okay this the third one we're gonna come
to benefit that again he's maybe just
argument's sake let's carry on
everything that I've said so far the
causality the composition the fallacy of
composition the inductive reasoning it
doesn't make a difference and the reason
is because there's an even more glaring
issue that's staring us right in the
face that I ignored for so long until
somebody showed it to me and I thought
my God how didn't I think of that before
and I said my god because old habits die
hard the problem is in the first premise
again whatever begins to exist has a
cause now people don't spend enough time
just thinking about what this implies
when have you ever seen anything begin
to exist well I made a little list
examples of things that have been
created out of nothing well I made a
little list well I made a little list
well I made a little list that's what
that means firstly of course we have the
universe when the universe came into
existence it truly did come into
existence out of nothing okay because
for the universe to be born if there was
something before it then that would be
encompassed by the universe so this did
truly begin to exist out of nothing
this is his contention against Mohammadi
job that he's being taken out of context
what I'm about to show you just after
this is going to put this whole thing to
bed and for him to claim that he job is
dishonest in lying I'm going to show it
with a 20-second clip but let's finish
this off because we're gonna get
benefited out of this way yeah maybe
he's just quoting argument's sake let's
carry on second
oh it's not broken at all that's it that
is it the universe there's nothing else
now okay sure what about a car you say
there's a there's a mini plant just on
the road from where I live in Oxford
England and then cars come into
existence all the time there
but today really I mean sure
a car might come into existence but
haven't we really just rearranged a
bunch of pre-existing stuff and giving
it a new name now guys I'm going to show
you this very clip get ready so just
before we do that what is he saying he's
saying the only thing that would believe
that came from nothing this is what is
seen but still we're not gonna use the
idea because he could I didn't mean that
I was using an argument saying no
problem we as fears as most muhammediye
jobs are us we're seeing no problem we
can say okay we can't see everything
began to exist because these are all
pre-existent from this type of
pre-existing material we call back to
the universe well that's what we're
talking about
nobody ever came and used that argument
in here we're seeing for example that
the universe where did that come from
and remember the audio we said guys that
a necessary uncaused beam is the only
thing that can make sense because
otherwise everything is contingent on
something else is dependent on something
else he's claiming now that he job took
his words house context we saw two three
instances he's building his argument
from composition to coming in uttering
himself that it come from the point
argument guys this bit you're gonna
watch is going to dismantle the whole
thing for Alex babe I gave you a job
three times you first asked for I gave
it then you said the wrong color then
you said you change your mind all you
care about it's making yourself okay
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm wrong I'm
so sorry I'm so happy I'm so sorry sorry
they go thank you if I had more jobs
I'll give all of them to you and let's
watch this video guys anything that that
comes from it is is well how can
something come from nothing
this is a contention that I hear all the
time if something can come from nothing
why doesn't it happen all the time okay
if things can just pop into existence
why doesn't the car just appear right
here well there's a simple reason for
that okay guys now if somebody if cosmic
hey job I couldn't accept it yeah if he
genuinely did not believe the universe
doesn't come from nothing he would not
make the building argument from fear of
her the fallacy of composition QWOP
Bertrand Russell make his arguments and
pour that to a side right now he's
saying that one of the contentions to
that is what same thing that that comes
from it is is well how can something
comes from nothing these are the
contentions he's basically and somebody
some people come and see to him if
something can come from nothing why
doesn't it happen all the time he could
have seen hold on a second you've set up
believe that I would just say enough for
the argument see look what he does now
this is a contention that I hear all the
time if something can come from nothing
why doesn't it happen all the time
okay things can just pop into existence
why doesn't the car just appear right
here well there's a simple reason for
that whoa whoa oh oh whoa I thought you
said you don't believe it came from
nothing who are you explaining what -
all you had to say he was me I've
actually I believe that you don't ask me
because I don't believe that came from
nothing you are actually explaining your
expert you see this is one of the
contentions thrown us and this is how we
reply that in itself shows that you
believe that the universe came from
nothing and which is more confusing and
frustrating like my hit wife asking for
her job that was just to demonstrate how
we feel like ripping our hair how yeah
this was act by the way my wife doesn't
do that yeah that's how we feel Alex
now I messaged you on Twitter and I said
Alex where do you believe the universe
came from and this is what you said to
me oh I don't know
now I don't know first it was his job is
taking the words out of context you
didn't say it come from my thing then
here you're defending your very premise
you're defending me in the very same
video I dare you to come and tell me
that oh no you didn't mean that now
seriously I'm gonna lose our mind cuz
all we've heard from you is that he's
taken out of context etc I didn't mean
that
and
I meant something else I don't believe
that anymore if I said I don't think I
said that if I said that I meant a
different way and you know what is more
profound cosmic skeptic or cosmic a job
because you keep throwing the hijab
covering on this main argument
contingency right the only thing you
know when I look at you
cosmic a job I see a verse in the Quran
and living proof because what does Allah
say in the Quran in surah at all unless
says or is it that they created by none
by nothing yeah look what you're
claiming or are they themselves the
creators yeah or they or have they
created the heavens and the earth
Belair you Kenan no but they are sure of
nothing and that is exactly what every
single atheist does when they've come
from point to point you took my words
half-conscious you've done this you've
done the progra what they come down to I
asked you on Twitter I don't know but
you're the same person that was
defending the very contention of what
how can things come from nothing so how
dare you come and accuse Muhammad a job
from being dishonest when you yourself
in your very video are defending the
very contention if he said it's argument
sake you would not even answer that to
the finish off the press on my point for
one last time guys yeah to change the
point to try and make another point
let's let's just see what he goes on and
says so ok so you've been even
determinism yes and you said in your you
said in your speech in your thing a
universe from nothing you said that
determinism comes from the necessary
existence now this is the third time
that Muhammad hijab is quoted me and
this time I just can't find the quote I
mean I've looked and I can't find me
saying this it's possible that I did and
if I did and one of you finds that do
let me know but I doubtful that I ever
actually said this now usually I would
say something like well I'm sure I did
I'm sure I just can't find it but with
the amount of times that Muhammad hijab
has already misquoted me I'm skeptical
but again I'm just gonna grant for the
sake of argument that I did say this you
know you could guys you can see clearly
I mean hijab you can't what I've seen
from cosmic skeptic or cosmic hijab
which I'm gonna call him is flowing
hijab a covering
over this argument that is all he has
done nothing else now come and tell me
that I'm misconstrued and I took it was
out of state I dare you to come and say
that Alex I do because it's very clear
that you believe that now you think I
don't know put everything to a side this
is the argument please reply and answer
to it you are avoiding and dodging it
and throwing all kind of red herrings
the whole room is smelling of red
herrings brothers and sisters yeah
answer the main argument which is on the
screen there are contingent there are
dependent things within our universe
right and these dependent things rely on
one another to exist we say that we
require an independent uncaused
necessary being that has always been
there to give rise to this and for it to
all make sense
what is your contention to that you have
to tell us because even if we say the
universe is post-eternal its to
post-eternity relies on the creator for
example we as muslims believe in heaven
and hell it's going to exist eternally
but it relies on the power source of god
almighty to exist
so we're saying to you you cannot escape
even if you said the universe is being
there post-eternity pre-eternity it
still requires a necessary independent
being to exist just like the example we
gave and i'm gonna finish off with this
with with Wikipedia with Google Facebook
internet computer and electricity I'm
gonna finish off with this point guys
just to make it clear for you guys to
understand wikipedia says I know
everything feels it things is
self-sufficient like a human being yeah
oh I know everything I'm self-sufficient
arrogance yeah and then Google comes
along you can see Google as I don't know
some food or something I I found
everything yeah and tell her Peter fix
up yeah like as human beings we rely on
other things yeah then Facebook comes
and says I know everyone yeah just prove
a point to Google or Wikipedia I'm
stronger yeah and then Internet comes
and says I own you guys yet
without internet you can't do nothing ok
but is that that absolute is is the
Internet necessary
of course no it's not then comes along
the computer to prove that point I say
hold on a second mr. contingent Internet
I gave you life yeah mr. contingent
thing yes and then what happens to the
computer computer things he's the one
yeah and there comes along electricity
yeah there comes along electricity and
said you know what keep talking you
idiots basically I am the source of
power refusing all of them well guess
what even electricity is contingent is
dependent we're saying you require an
independent on cause being for
everything to make sense refute the
point not the person not add homonyms
attacking hey job he didn't say that
he's a bit harsh so what so bloody what
his job is atheist worst nightmare and
the source Hamlet sources and is so so
so bored you guys these guys are your
worst nightmare and you're just doing
everything to attempt their personal
character etc and all this kind of
behavior saying that he threatened isn't
nonsense
yeah you have insulted our Prophet peace
be upon him with no shame if I insulted
your mother and called them names
yeah and misconstrued something that she
may have gone away for it may be a
misconstrued how the hell would you feel
Alex you should be ashamed of yourself
you're an intelligent man behave like
one have intellectual arguments not his
job threatened my life accepted why
because he said you know you live
amongst Muslims if you utter these
statements you're gonna have hostility
this doesn't need to be physical this
can people despising you if you job
lived in an area where there's a fire
right oh yeah and you said to him hey
job you shouldn't do that because you
live in an area where your life could be
in danger this doesn't go with Muslim or
its thumbs cuz of anyone somebody can
despise you somebody can God knows just
and you took that and took it out of
context touch up on the argument to get
to the rest we want you to answer the
argument from contingency please
whatever your stance if it came from
nothing you don't know whatever answered
the argument from contingency thank you
till next time
assalamu alaikum what I'm trying here to
cosmic skeptic cosmic a job don't be for
on those hijabs and covering those
beautiful arguments thank you